[Musique]
ce soir je vais vous parler d'autorité
je vais même faire l'éloge de l'autorité
et pour cela je vous emmène comme ancien
commandant j'ai eu ce privilège
ancien commandant du sous marin que vous
venez de voir plonger
je vous emmène à bord du triomphant je
pense que peu d'entre vous ont été à
bord d'un sous marin nucléaire lanceur
d'engins un sous marin qui plonge à plus
de 300 m un sous marin qui supporte pas
cette immersion 30 atmosphère 30 fois la
charge ici un sous marin qui est à la
fois une centrale nucléaire
une base de lancement de missile est un
modeste village de 111 habitants
le triomphant a appareillé il ya
maintenant trente cinq jours de brest il
se trouve à des milliers de kilomètres
de brest à des milliers de kilomètres de
toute assistance à des milliers de
kilomètres des familles à bord 111
hommes et femmes puisque depuis le
printemps dernier
il ya maintenant aussi des femmes à bord
des sous-marins nucléaires lanceurs
d'engins alors montons à bord
je suis heureux de vous faire découvrir
ce monde qui c'est vrai est clos mais
qui est un monde passionnant et que je
vais vous faire découvrir
alors si l'on regarde le triomphant on
va rencontrer
bien sûr beaucoup d'équipements mais ce
qui est le plus important sans doute ce
sont les hommes et les femmes
commençons par ce central qui est le
central opérations le saint des saints
du sous marin dans ce saint des saints
des sous marins l'officiel chef du quart
un officier qui n'a même pas 30 ans et
qui a la responsabilité de l'ensemble du
bateau
le commandant lui a délégué toutes ses
responsabilités pendant les trois heures
que vont durer souccar dans ce poste de
contrôle
opération six opérateurs sont braqués
sur des consoles pour écouter ce qui se
passe autour
dans un sous marin on ne voit rien la
seule façon de savoir les menaces de
savoir quel et l'environnement c'est
d'écouter et il ya là un homme clé
l'oreille d'or un homme qui est capable
en écoutant la musique de dire c'est un
porte avions américain
c'est un sous marin russe où c'est un
cargo ou peut-être c'est simplement une
baleine si l'on se déplace vers
l'arrière ici toute la puissance du
réacteur
toute la puissance des machines là aussi
des hommes et des femmes jeunes c'est
d'eux que dépend la propulsion du bateau
ils sont concentrés aussi parce que
certes faire avancer le bateau mais le
moins bruyant possible et là ils sont
quatre ou cinq actuellement un peu
préoccupé parce que l'une des turbines à
une vibration un peu anormal
revenons vers l'avant les 16 tubes
lance-missiles sont surveillés par des
hommes qui passent des programmes
informatiques des spécialistes de
l'informatique
formé depuis des années à ces missiles
pour l'instant tout à l'air d'aller bien
ici au milieu un poste très important
notamment parce que c'est là que se
trouvent les usines à oxygène sans
oxygène
à bord on ne survit plus et il faut
produire soi-même son oxygène là aussi
des très grands spécialistes sont
rassemblés revenons vers l'avant et nous
nous trouvons ici à l'hôpital
et oui il y à un hôpital et la tête de
cet hôpital
aujourd'hui en ce moment et bien le
médecin c'est une toubib est elle
actuellement elle est en train d'opérer
une fracture ouverte
hors de question de ne pas réduire cette
fracture à bord enfin pour être un peu
plus léger nous terminons ici par la
cafétéria
là aussi les hommes sont clés et le
cuisinier et le boulanger parce qu'ils
savent qu'à chacun des 2 x 70 au pacte
le saut en service ils seront jugés et
noté voilà les hommes et les femmes du
triomphe alors me direz-vous c'est bien
de rentrer dans votre sous-marin
mais l'autorité ou est-elle d'autorité
c'est vous le commandant autorités pas
tout de suite la première source
d'autorité
la première source d'énergie qui motive
ces hommes et ces femmes c'est la
mission d'ailleurs avant de partir
l'amiral s'est adressé à l'équipage du
triomphant en leur disant vous votre
mission c'est la protection de nos
intérêts c'est la protection de la
france
c'est sur vous que ça repose pendant 70
jours pendant 70 jours
vous resterez en mer vous n'avez pas le
droit de revenir avant soixante dix
jours vous devez revenir aux boutons
sont idiots vous ne devez jamais être
détecté la mission c'est leur mission et
c'est pour ça que chacun quel que soit
son grade
quel que soit son poste est convaincu
que la première source d'autorité qui
est importante pour lui c'est cette
mission est pour rien au monde il ne
ferait quelque chose qui puisse arrêter
la mission alors la deuxième source
bien sûr c'est vous commandant pas
encore la deuxième source d'autorité et
bien être
dans chacun de ses 111 hommes et femmes
oui vous me direz ils ont la
responsabilité
mais l'autorité eh bien oui parce qu'ils
ont une responsabilité
defacto derrière cette responsabilité
ils ont une forme d'autorité la toubib
qui est en train d'opérer
elle a autorité sur l'humain et la
réparation de l'humain les hommes qui
répare l'usiné oxygène qui vient de
tomber en panne
il représente aussi une autorité s'ils
ne parviennent pas déparé panne et la
mission peut s'interrompre
même chose à l'arrière pour cette
turbine qui fait un peu de bruit même
chose aussi pour l'oreille d'or qui
semble très perplexe aujourd'hui parce
qu'il entend un bruit qui n'a pas
reconnu et donc chacun de ces hommes et
de ces femmes qui sont présentes à bord
chacun est non seulement une place de
responsabilité mais une source
une énergie d'autorité la mission chacun
des onze deuxième source d'autorité et
la troisième à la troisième c'est vrai
le commandant est l'autorité mais le
commandant ne peut rien si ces hommes et
ces femmes ne considère pas que la
mission est une forme de transcendance
et que c'est elle qui est prioritaire et
le commandant ne peut rien si chacun de
ces hommes et de ces femmes ne fait pas
ce qu'il a à faire jusqu'au bout jusqu'à
se dépasser et au fond ils arrivent en
fédérateur
d'ailleurs pour être commandant de
sous-marin nucléaire lanceur d'engins et
pour comprendre tout cela pour
comprendre la technique du marin pour
comprendre la technique du sous marin
il n'a fallu 25 ans 25 ans qui sont pas
simplement la technique mais qui sont
aussi l'appréciation du management de la
culture et du sens de la mission
alors aujourd'hui bien aujourd'hui je
suis le fédérateur
je suis celui qui va aller chercher et
demandé à chacun de rands au maximum ce
qu'il peut faire avec ce qu'il a je suis
celui qui va réconforter
celui qui aura moins de morale
parce qu'il pense à sa famille qu'il a
laissé mais sans eux je ne suis rien
alors la mission chacun d'entre nous le
commandant ces salles autorités c'est ça
aujourd'hui l'énergie
c'est ça la bonne conception de
l'autorité dans 35 jours
le triomphant rentrera à brest les
hommes et les femmes seront fatigués et
puis on finira après la manoeuvre du
matin après avoir fait surface la nuit
et avoir retrouvé le goût de le goût de
la mer et au petit matin le soleil on
sera dans le bassin sud de l'île longue
bien amarré la mission est terminée et
là pour dire que la mission est terminée
il ya une phrase culte terminé barre et
machines une phrase est mise depuis la
passerelle et qui va se reprendre dans
l'ancien hall du bateau une phrase qui
n'est pas simplement une phrase type qui
est aussi une émission ça va
nous avons fait notre mission on rentre
à la maison et ce soir nous retrouverons
nos fronts ça a été ça ma vie pendant de
nombreuses années
je suis encore ému en en parlant parce
que l m'apprennent y est après avoir
quitté la mère je me suis rendu compte
que là où j'étais
j'étais toujours imprégné tout cela
alors le sens ce soir vous qui êtes là
dans cet amphithéâtre
vous qui êtes chef d'entreprise vous qui
avez un restaurant ou quéven commerce
phuket à la mairie ou qui est à la
chambre de commerce vous qui avez une
équipe vous qui avez tous ces hommes et
ces femmes dont vous avez la
responsabilité
vous qui vous êtes s'engager eh bien je
nous souhaite
à tous ensemble nous toujours ressentir
cette émotion que nous avons quand
l'autorité est une autorité bien
comprise bien vécu au service de la
mission au service de chacun et non pas
son propre service le sens de l'autorité
le vrai sens de l'autorité
c'est cette très belle vertu au service
des uns et des autres alors ce soir je
vous nomme comme cadeau la traduction du
latin auctoritas ce et qui veut dire
faire grandir
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]